[MUSIC PLAYING]
VINT CERF: Today, I want to rant
about the Internet of Things.
MALE SPEAKER: Have
any of you thought
about what the living room
of the future will look like?
MALE SPEAKER: This isn't
just another web service.
These devices are in your
home, your office, car.
They can record data.
They can control things.
MALE SPEAKER: All of
this put together,
what it allows us
to do is really
to build the next generation
of intelligent applications.
MALE SPEAKER: And the
opportunity is pretty immense.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where you
guys come into play in figuring
out what can be done.
MALE SPEAKER: So without
further ado, let's dive in.
MALE SPEAKER: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to a session entitled
"The Future of the Living
Room."
MALE SPEAKER: So what
we thought we'd do
is have a session
where we can sit down
with some of the
important people
on the Brillo and Weave team.
MALE SPEAKER: And this is
my personal favorite recipe
for a very specific
use case, a recipe
for building one of something.
It's kind of a bag of goodies
to make app dev easier.
MALE SPEAKER: What we
want to do is build
a home that's [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: This is all
about new paradigms for HCI.
You can develop
services in the language
that best fits the
problem at hand.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: We're really
excited to see what you can
build with Brillo and Weave.
Thank you.